I'm Marjorie tivan I'm the Commissioner
for the New York City Commission for the
United Nations counselor quorin protocol
and I'm the service the treasurer of New
York City global partners first I want
to thank Columbia University our host
and today and co-sponsor and thank
president Bollinger senior vice
president Robert Kasdan a political
science professor ester Fuchs who
serving as our moderator and will come
to the podium later on and also mention
that Mayor feldberg who is the dean
emeritus at Columbia Business School it
serves as global partners president
global partners has produced eight
summits all in partnership with city
agencies this one with the New York City
Department of Education of course it's
their best practices in their work and
their fabulous team that made this
summit possible and we also want to
thank all of our international panelists
for their expert contributions we had
fabulous panels this morning and I and
their workshops all afternoon the
underwriter of today's summit events is
at Columbia is Pearson other parts of
this three-day summit were underwritten
by Bank of America verizon and the
mayor's fund to advance New York City
thank you to all donors and board
members of global partners there is a
full list on the cards at your table now
I have the honor of introducing someone
who's made a profound difference in the
lives of countless New York City
children Chancellor Joel Klein how lucky
we are
lucky we are to have him as he steps
down from the extraordinary challenge of
leading new york city's public schools
when he became Chancellor the
conventional wisdom was that our schools
were broken were failing were had failed
and he launched a comprehensive reform
strategy that has brought coherence and
capacity to the school system and he's
transformed it in ways that you have all
heard about so that the Obama
administration looks to us as a model
joel is no slouch as everybody knows
he's led a system of 1,700 schools with
1.1 million students in 136 thousand
employees he did it with great passion
and great results Joel Klein is a
graduate of the new york city public
schools and columbia university and
harvard law school he served as deputy
White House Counsel to President Clinton
assistant US attorney general in charge
of the Antitrust Division at the US
Department of Justice and as chairman
and CEO of bertelsmann Joel on behalf of
city government and the city's children
we're grateful for your service please
welcome Joel Klein
Thank You Marjorie and really I want to
thank global partners for the incredible
work they're doing convening this with
so many friends from the city and
colleagues throughout the world many of
whom have come to know over the years to
all be here together at my alma mater
talking about public schools in the city
that gave me a public school education
that changed my entire life and about a
week after the mayor announced my
resignation so this is a highly
emotional time for me the good news i
like to say is once your resignation is
resigned you can afford to be more
candid than you are previously so you'll
get me unvarnished today and those of
you who don't know me that's saying
something because even varnish thumb on
varnishes but unfortunately the other
half of that is since the mayor
announced that it's really been a
whirlwind in our city and so i haven't
had a chance to sleep much so while i'll
be more candid i'll also be more
incoherent and bear with me for that I
mean again I think what global partners
is doing is so important in so many
levels it reflects what's going on in
our world our interconnectedness but I
want to say one of their programs that
I'm especially grateful for his global
partners jr. which is connecting
students into new york city public
schools two students throughout the
world and I've always said that the kids
today are going to grow up and live in a
very very different world than the one
that we grew up in and is so important
to get them early on thinking about
different cultures different economies
different nations and how interdependent
we have all become and I think that's
probably why this conference when i
walked in i said to Marjorie you know
there's so much buzz and energy in the
room and i think that's a tribute to the
fact that education globally has really
become sexy and i think that's a good
thing because when i started this job it
was really viewed as a backwater in so
many ways but certainly in you
west and now I see throughout the world
in the work I've done in other countries
and I've been privileged to work with a
number of other countries etc and people
really are trying to think very
differently about the educational
challenges we face and I want to talk
about it in two dimensions today the
first which I really hope people can
wrap their head around you're really two
big points that I want to make one is
we're educating children today for an
entirely different world it's not just
the global dimensions of that world that
they need to understand but it is an
economy that is entirely different from
the world in which I grew up in the
1950s if I convince you or nothing else
today I hope you will take a good look
at a book by to harvard economists and
being here at Columbia I shouldn't do
this but as I said what the hell so
Claudia Goldin and Lawrence cats is
called the race between education and
technology and what it points out is
that the kids of tomorrow will compete
an entirely different economy and the
skills they will need will be very
different let me give you one statistic
that just strikes me is so powerful in
1950 when I was growing up in New York
City about sixty percent of our
workforce in the United States had not
completed secondary school and about
eight percent or college graduates today
about eight percent having completed
secondary school and almost forty
percent or college graduates and that is
going to accelerate that's not going to
stabilize that will accelerate and the
pay differential has more than doubled
for somebody who dropped out of high
school compared to a college graduate so
the challenges we face are enormous at a
second point that I want to make and I'm
somewhat humbled making you there are
people in this room doing such
exceptional work throughout the world
and you know one of the things in many
places America said we lecture others
too much well in education we really
should be listening to many others in
many ways people doing extraordinary
things because
education is a place where America
really is falling behind as the mayor
said this morning and so I want to talk
to you looking through that particular
telescope I've been here for eight and a
half years unlike many people in the
room I'm wasn't a career educator have a
deep passionate about education as being
the fulcrum to which human beings live
the American dream that has really come
from nowhere and rise to extraordinary
heights in our society and a deep sense
when I took this job I was fortunate to
be picked by the mayor a little over 8
now 8 years ago took this job a sense
that the public education system i went
to in the city was very different from
the one that i was going to take over in
2002 and i'd like to look at this
through that lens both from the city and
the nation and tell you what i think i
have learned and hope i challenge you
and let me also say i do hope you find
what i say controversial because unless
things are controversial and we're
prepared to look candidly at the
challenges we face it will not change
and certainly here in New York and in
America we need to change rapidly in
order to ensure that our children are
capable of meeting the demands of this
21st century very different global
economy I like to start with a quote
from about 25 27 years ago at that time
we had a Presidential Commission in
America issued a report called a nation
at risk in 1983 and the key quote known
to so many of us is the educational
foundations of our society of being
eroded by a rising tide of mediocrity if
an unfriendly foreign power had
attempted to impose on America the
educational performance that exists
today we might have viewed it as an act
of war it's 1983 two things have
happened to them and please get your
head around these two things because
otherwise its discussion will not impact
the way it needs to impact
first from 1983 when we were a nation at
risk to today in real dollars
inflation-adjusted dollars we have
doubled the amount of money we spend on
education twice as much and second of
all I think it's indisputable that today
we are a nation more at risk than when
we were in 1983 something is
fundamentally wrong with that picture
we've spent twice as much the demands
our children are much greater and yet we
are more at risk today I could go
through lots and lots of metrics the
mayor and mayor feldburg went through
some of those this morning where we are
nationally how our graduation rates high
school and college are falling compared
to the rest of the world so on and so
forth but suffice it to say by any
relevant metric we are not educating our
kids I wanted to be loud but not
definitely we are not educating our
children at the levels that they will
need to be successful in the 21st
century now I want to ask you because
ours is an inquiring group what are
wonderful things about educators are
we're prepared to look at any challenge
and try to think through why why is it
why is it that we've doubled our
investment and yet we haven't changed in
any significant way the outcomes that we
were getting what's the explanation for
that and the answer I think is quite
frankly we keep doing the same things
expecting different results and that is
the definition of insanity if you keep
doing the same things you're not going
to get different results and simply
doing more of the same things will not
get you different results so no question
education is a pedagogical challenge
curriculums matter class size matters
but those things have been the fair of
education reform for as far back as we
can remember and yet we haven't changed
the outcomes and those are the things
that matter so for me
the real question is why we don't look
at something that some people want to
dismiss and that is the way
fundamentally we structure our systems
the incentives there were Wars the
consequences the way we create a system
that has the power to change and there's
something that people say to me said
well you know education is not a
business right I understand that we're
not in the jaw our job is not to make
money but damn it we are in the business
of educating children and we're not
doing it remotely at the levels we need
to do and why should we think for a
second that practices that work in every
other environment wouldn't work here why
should we think that innovation which is
the engine that drives this and
virtually every other economy is
something that we should have to or be
afraid of and rely on a simple trivial
phrase that education is not a business
organizations that are poorly designed
organizations that incentivize the wrong
things will get poor outcomes so for me
from the beginning working with the
mayor ours was a systems focus we had a
vision that was unheard of in k-12
education Michelle K Hilla was then my
senior adviser here today she
articulated it she said let's say from
day one it's not about a great school
system nobody goes to a system it's
about a system comprised of great
schools and in that shift something
powerful was said because I have a
simple end vision that no place do I
know in America has achieved we cannot
call ourselves successful until every
single school is a school that every one
of you would allow me to send your
children to and I promise you I've asked
every audience I've been to would you
allow me to randomly assign your child
to a public school in New York City and
the answer is never and I ask people to
think
whose children should go to the schools
we don't send our own children to and
until we answer that question we are not
going to get serious about school reform
so the report reforms we put in place
were designed to be aggressive last week
there was a retrospective a whole bunch
academics talking about them and a
comment that struck me most was by the
Dean the academic dean at Harvard School
of Education Bob Schwartz and he said of
New York City it's the most dramatic and
thoughtful set of large-scale reforms
going on anywhere in the country and
that those reforms were getting traction
there's lots of numbers I could give you
the one I'm most proud of is today the
graduation high school graduation rate
is 20 points higher than it was when we
started that is 15,000 children a year
graduating and of that thank you as a
result of that compared to when we
started over 10,000 more children are
going to the city universities and
others going to additional private and
other colleges so you're thinking about
the impact you're talking about for
10,000 kids plus a chance to go to
college and move their education forward
I'd be the first to say the mayor said
it this morning we're not remotely where
we need to be more than two-thirds of
more than one-third of our children
don't graduate on time that would not
have happened in the absence of two
things something the mayor grasps
instinctively and something I believe
deeply which is if you don't look at the
systems challenges and how we deliver
this same kind of issues in health care
in any place else if you don't look at
those issues you will not succeed and
second of all if you fear controversy
you're in the wrong business status quos
as my former deputy Chris Cerf who used
to circulate more Machiavelli
Machiavelli quotes than any but status
quos are fiercely defended I run a 23
billion
dollar system people are not going to
allow me to change it and realign it and
create different systems and incentives
just because I went to Charm School
people will push back vigorously against
those kinds of changes and if you're not
prepared to engage that then this is not
the work for you it is not the work for
people who need on a daily basis to be
popular loved or admired and it's not
the work for people or afraid of real
controversy and also people who are
afraid of ever making a mistake because
one wonderful thing about hewing to the
status quo is you're unlikely to change
much and in that respect unlikely to run
down some pathways that don't work but
if we stay there we will continue to get
the results we're getting so let me
focus on four things they're not the
only things lots other things matter
standards matter curriculums matter or
extended day matter I could go through a
long list but I want to give you four
ideas to chew on on those long plane
rides home that all of you will be
taking from outside the city and the
long subway rides home for all of you in
the city as the mayor said people in the
city spend an hour and a half to go to
school every day the first is the Y's
are the wisest words in the entire time
I've been here and there from
surprisingly Albert Shanker who is the
most iconic teachers union leader in
America ever he was the head of our
union here in New York went on to be the
head of the National Union Woody Allen
made him famous and sleeper and the
words are referred to are the words I
live by he said the key is that unless
there's accountability we will never get
the right system listen to this as long
as there are no consequences if kids or
adults don't perform as long as there
are no consequences of kids or adults
don't perform as long as the discussion
is not about education and student
outcomes not about inputs not about
sighs not about budget student outcomes
then we're playing the game as to as the
power and quite frankly an American I
expect so many other places the game we
play in education is who has the power
is it the union is it the district is it
the school board is it the principal is
it the teachers these are the games the
adults struggling for power while the
children not getting the results no
system can work if it's not built on
accountability now people want to say
okay what's the right measurement and so
forth there are no perfect measurements
photos if you read Jim Collins good to
great he explains us in detail but you
need to find intelligent sensible ways
to measure you don't like standardized
tests come up with a better way of real
measurement but don't do what public
education does which is its to
accountability in every way possible we
have got to stop thinking that the
system because it's well intentioned
needn't be accountable and my challenge
to everyone is those that don't like the
metrics we use show me better metrics
show me better measurements but if a
system doesn't know what it's trying to
achieve then it has no way of knowing
whether it's doing well or poorly how to
improve it what things you knew to drive
it so much if we have done in this city
has been built off of accountability and
data controversial oh it's been we put a
letter grade on schools comparing apples
to apples our parents like that we put a
letter grade and those that don't
perform well we take action against we
don't believe there's a wizard of oz and
education at the central headquarters
who can wave a wand and fix a school
schools are dynamic organizations where
culture and leadership and human
interactions matter and when they become
dysfunctional and when they have low
expectations as so many do when they
explain away why poor kids can learn
those are schools that need to be
and we're unafraid to do it second big
idea if I could wave a wand and change
one thing tomorrow I would make teaching
the most respected most sought-after
profession in this country in other
countries here today in other countries
here today that's what it is but in
America we have failed to
professionalize teaching there are a lot
of reasons for that the mayor cited a
couple we basically adopted a factory
model so what do we do for teachers we
built it on the following four pillars
lockstep a life tenure seniority and
pension that is a factory model nowhere
in there do your reward excellence
nowhere in there do you think about the
people you're recruiting into this
profession every study shows us those
nations getting the best results recruit
their teachers from the top third in
some instances top court or even top ten
percent of their college graduates we're
not doing that in America we need this
country's best and brightest excited
about teaching because that will
transform k to 12 education and that
will also change the world for our
children so we need to move from a
factory based to a professional model
where excellence becomes the hallmark
when people used to tell me a teacher as
a teacher as a teacher I used to say
these people live with their head in the
sand I know from astoria where I grew up
there was some teachers Sydney Harrison
particular my physics teacher who
changed my life and believe me I hadn't
had him my life would have been in a
different direction so I know the value
of teaching to transform lives and we
have got to make teaching the argot the
currency of what drives reform third big
idea and this one is really
controversial is we've got to stop
thinking of education as a monopoly
provider and understanding
importance of competition and choice
remember when I said to you before that
nobody here would allow me to simply
randomly assign your child to every
school in the city everyone here insists
on choice for your children right if you
didn't like the neighborhood school
you'd move you'd find another school if
you had to you send your kid to private
school but you would never simply say
well that's all it is and I will take it
think about this why is it that k to 12
education in America is not respected
globally but our college system is there
are several reasons but one is college
system is not a monopoly operator this
school that we stand here today has to
every year compete with other great
schools to a draw both the best faculty
and the best students that's what makes
a great University and Katie 12
education particularly are needed
neediest children and kids who grow up
in the toughest communities they get one
choice or nothing and one of the things
that may or didn't you can understand
why the adults like that because if you
get a guaranteed number of kids every
year you know you're in business no
matter what we should have to earn our
kids just the way Columbia College earns
its kids and we should insist on that
for everybody not just for ourselves to
core initiatives that we did one we open
up well over a hundred charter schools
for those of you not familiar charter
school is a public school that is run by
a private board they design curriculum
center there rigorously accountable you
can shut them down for non-performance
we put them in our high needs
communities and what we have created is
a dynamic system of choice with two
outcomes parents much more demanding and
in fact nearby schools understanding the
importance for them to improve to make
sure that they become competitive
competition works throughout every
sector of the economy it can help us in
k-12 education every study that's been
done to in particular at Stanford's show
that those charter schools and what's
the equivalent of double-blind studies
people who applied and got admitted
people who applied and didn't get admit
that they got much much better results
we did a similar thing with our high
schools we've opened up over 250 new
high schools replacing large failing
schools in this city and we gave all our
students choice and once again now
there's no dispute a recent study by
MDRC one of the leading educational
researchers in this country showed
studying over four years dramatic
differences kids who are applied to
those schools and kids who got in and
didn't get in so it's truly double-blind
dramatic differences in a results we get
including seven point difference in our
graduation rate which is about one third
of the achievement gap in this city so
let's stop thinking that competition is
somehow a no-no in public education we
insist on it for our kids we should
provided to all kids and a fourth thing
goes back to where I started when is
innovation going to become a driver I
want all of you to tell me how much
innovation is going on in your systems
you know if you fell asleep in America
hundred fifty years ago be one teacher
30 kids in a classroom and if you woke
up on a 50 years later be one teacher 30
kids right and what we'd have this goofy
thing called a computer lab and we need
to teach our kids how to use that's a
skill to you our kids know how to use a
computer question is why are we using a
computer to change the way we deliver
instruction to our children why are we
thinking entirely different ways about
the models that we use in New York we're
doing that you're going to see one of
those tomorrow the school of one
cutting-edge got at the top of Time
magazine cutting-edge one of its 50
great inventions of last year I've got
program as a man here from an Israeli
group called time to know it's got
really rich content in a dynamically
engaging program I met with the kids in
a school in central Brooklyn last week
the content enables the teacher to be so
much better think about it this way not
everybody can deliver a great lecture on
the Civil War but there are some people
who can who can light your mind up
including the teachers mind
and why are we bringing that now two
kids when I was a kid I loved physics I
studied Richard Fineman the great Nobel
Prize physicists I studied his lectures
at Caltech I have never seen people
lectured like Richard Feynman did on
physics why would we possibly deny that
why do we stick with a model it says a
teacher has to plan a different or
sometimes multiple lesson plans each day
rather than use technology and
innovation I've got to school we just
opened a new American Academy for
teachers responsible for 60 children
collectively one's a master teacher and
it's hierarchical down through an
apprentice they stay with them for six
years is it going to be the greatest
thing since sliced bread I don't know
but why are we afraid to innovate why do
we have this model and we can't break it
in our minds look at the school of one
tomorrow think about the rest of the
world and what's going on with
innovation in other industries think
about medicine you think anybody could
have fallen asleep twenty years ago in
medicine wake up today and practice it
you think they have a computer lab for
doctors but let me give you my favorite
example in n da news so we open up these
new small schools and as a result some
of these children and particularly in
highly challenged communities there's
only two or three who want to take
advanced placement physics or advanced
base placement math and so the school
can't afford a teacher now there are
some great online courses for those of
you who don't know if you pass an
Advanced Placement the college board
designs a test if you pass it a level 3
or higher you get college credit but in
New York State they had a rule that said
you can't get high school credit because
you have to have a live teacher so i
said i went up to Albany where the state
government is and I met with the
officials and I said see here's the
problem we can't have a live teach you
would like to take them online and if
the child passes the course and gets a 3
or higher we'd like to give them high
school credit waive this requirement
called seat time you know what they told
me they said well that's not the way we
do it here and I said I understand
I said that's why I came up for a
Waverly so that I could do it that way
down see but yours you're laughing but
for the last seven eight years this seat
time requirement blocked us from
allowing so many of these youngsters to
take an AP course now why do we have a
seat time requirement pure and simple it
is a feather bedding rule it is a job
protection rule to make sure if we don't
have an adult there you cannot get
credit that hurt our children so let me
wrap it up this way there's so much we
need to do to learn from and challenge
each other I speak for no country or no
city but my own in saying the following
that if we rest with the status quo pat
ourselves on the back and think we are
remotely where we need to be we are
going to allow our children to inherit a
world that they are unprepared for the
core lesson from the book I mentioned at
the outset the book the race between
education and technology America built
the greatest middle class in the world
because we educated our people to
unprecedented levels in the first 75
years of the 20th century we were the
first out of the blocks for universal
secondary school and after the world war
with all sorts of GI programs really
dramatically increased college going and
college completion we are in significant
danger of creating an elite
entrepreneurial class and a growing
under class it's happening as we speak
you see the problem with educational
crisis they don't occur overnight and
economic crisis boom an educational
crisis 13 years for generation we have
got to challenge ourselves not to think
a little bit differently we've got to
stop being incremental and realize
certainly in my city I believe in my
nation we have got to realize that if
we're afraid to be bold we will fail and
if we keep washing ourselves with the
same warm water and telling ourselves
with the same soporific that a little
more of this or a little bit of that is
going to get dramatically different
outcomes it may be comfortable for the
adults from the status quo works quite
well it will not be comfortable for the
future this nation or the children whose
fiduciaries we serve thank you very much
the Chancellor has agreed to take some
questions so if you just put your hands
up we'll get the mic to you and we'll
take will try and take two or three
questions at a time if that's necessary
so um any questions you were that
effective Joel or intimidating I'm not
sure which answer do go ahead you ask
the first question is okay thank you
you've seen the movie waiting for
superman and ifs what is your response
to that i have seen the moody movie
waiting for superman i think it's a very
powerful and effective movie it's been
criticized and lacks a certain amount of
nuance been criticized that it focuses
only on good charter schools they should
have focused on some great public
schools we have some here in New York
but it tees up the following question
which is critical in America you know
one of the things I left out of my
comments and I'm glad you gave me this
chance so many people have told me that
there's something about poverty or
something about dysfunctional families
and therefore we're not going to be able
to educate children to a very high level
so let's forget about that but the truth
that Superman the lie that Superman
exposes is not only can we but we are
doing that we have schools in this city
that are educating children who people
told me couldn't be educated to higher
level at the same level as our gifted
and talented
schools kids that are admitted randomly
by lottery high-poverty 100% children of
color what Superman says to the nation
is we can do this we haven't done it at
scale I don't think it's all about
charters I think it's about great
schools public or charter but the
question we've got answers why haven't
we done it when we know it can be done
that's the question it tees up the thing
that drives me nuts about academics at a
great academic institution I said they
figured out that most of the variance in
terms of student outcomes can be
explained by demographics etc right but
they have to understand something you
can only make that assertion if you hold
the quality of education equal and so in
fact what we know systematically in
America the kids with the greatest
challenges the kids who come from the
most difficult communities are
systematically getting a much poorer
education so to tell me that kids who
get a poor education growing up and
challenge families that's about
demographics it's taking away the only
important issue which is we don't even
remotely know how much education can
overcome demographics as a kid who grew
up in public housing I thank God my
teachers never thought demographics with
destiny cuz I would never be here today
other questions yes thank you Joe I know
this isn't going to be your problem and
you know for that we're all sorry
because I'm sorry to see you go but
we're all facing enormous budget
deficits in coming years New York and
every other city and state in the United
States and you could argue that levels
at which we've been funding education
k20 aren't sustainable over the long run
so you have some fun I think it's an
enormous challenge I wish it weren't
true but I would make two points one
that's a reality we now face I started
by making a following point we doubled
our k to 12 investment from 83 to 2010
and didn't produce a lot of results so
the real question is not simply how much
but how
I have a couple of three thoughts one
the current system that lets you get
more money for every year you're in the
system that seniority driven and pension
driven has to be restructured we have
got to reward people on the front end is
in and and you know in Detroit they try
to make it work the way we try to make
it work and thank goodness if you see
what's happening with GM today a
revitalized industry that's built much
more on excellence rather than job
security and lifetime pension can work
second thing Susan I think we all have
to think about how you use technology to
really grapple with these issues there's
a lot more we can do my example which is
slightly humorous but to a point why
can't we say particularly in middle and
certainly in high school that a lot of
our kids appear you today couple of
periods that they are doing online
coursework there is ways for us to think
differently nobody would like to see
education funded at a higher level than
I would I believe deeply in it but when
you're faced with an economic challenge
at least certainly when my family was
people came together and thought what
what are better ways to do these things
we need to think about that together in
education when you ask a question please
identify yourself that was Susan firming
the president of our teachers college
here at Columbia University Thank You
Susan next question please hey how you
doing I'm Bridal column principle of
scholars academy public school of rock
awaits a 6th grade through 12th grade
school I want to first thank Chancellor
and transfers office because this year
there's something called conceptual
consolidation which enables principals
who were empowered to leverage their
resources and spend their money on
priorities for the school that will
really impact those student outcomes one
of the issues that we we were able to
impact in our school you're talking
about technology Chancellor Klein was
Spanish instruction for example we were
able to use conceptual consolidation
redeploy our resources to purchase
laptops for every kid in Spanish class a
teacher who for year after year
aarons would complain about and we
couldn't grapple with what the
disconnect was with the teacher and the
students the technology has empowered
that teacher because she has
strengthened organization facilitation
that lend itself to getting kids
learning independently with technology
the kids are doing phenomenally the
teacher is flourishing and it was me it
was the budgetary fulcrum that enabled
us to make that purchase to make that
happen so my question is that's me what
time it is i build you a clock my
question is are there any conversations
happening that you're aware of at the
state level to enable school principals
to take New York State textbook law of
money and conceptually consolidated so
that we can make intelligent purchases
with those funds and actually accomplish
some objectives to impact those learning
outcomes yes another example of my AP
example first of all Brian tiny is
extraordinary principal out in far
rockaway doing just incredible or but
like he said because we in power
principles and gave him discretion I
didn't tell him to do this online
spanish program he figured out himself
and you know what systems work much
better that way and people like him are
much more inspired as a result the
answer is of course there are
discussions but once again the Wizard of
Oz theory of Education why I should tell
you whether to buy a textbook or go
online or hold a Saturday morning class
for your kids why I should do that for
sixteen hundred and eighty schools so
baffles me and yet that's what k to 12
education is full of and so to me let us
give you the money no matter how much it
is going to susan's question and then
hold you accountable the likelihood of
two things happening or greatest one the
likelihood that you will deploy that
money more effectively than I could from
central headquarters for seventeen
hundred schools in my view is a thousand
percent clear and second of all we might
learn something you know your colleagues
might see what you did that's different
from somebody else when I got here I
still can't get my head over people said
to me he said if you have a 300 children
in the school you got an assistant
principal to 90
so they came to me and said can I can I
get a principal assistant principal for
290 how would I know whether you need
assistant principal or a left fielder I
mean how would I figure that out for
other people and yet we have textbook
money categorical money for this look
let these people like him and the others
who are here i see sauna is here and
others from children let them do the
tough work in his school communities of
dealing with tight budgets and let's all
those smart people at central let's just
figure out how to hold them accountable
in a way they buy into not to try to
micromanage them into great results we
can't do it we haven't done it and we
won't do it next question over here uh
Chancellor I'm Rafael Parente from real
huge on they didn't Brazil I'm on so we
had lunch on Tuesday you know I did
enjoy yourself let's do I'm telling
other people anyhow thank you so much
for your very inspiring words and you
know it's been incredible how much we've
learned since we arrived and for sure
we'll take so much of new things to to
apply in Rio but I was just wondering if
there were any things that you wish you
could have done during all this
revolution in public education in New
York and you couldn't or what would be
the next big step in new york city's
public educational system so i'd say
first of all to the--and you know we had
the privilege claudia i heard was
spectacular on a panel today i'm at the
least bit surprised but we had the
chance over lunch to learn from you and
some of the incredible tough work you're
doing in the favelas and everything and
I am just inspired by your willingness
not to say that kids who face the
toughest circumstance somehow we can
only educate a little bit so in that
respect really its inspiration answer
your question I'll give you the best
advice I can give anybody and I learned
it actually from a friend called michael
barber who did this work for Tony Blair
in a period about any Turner to 21st
century and one was all over barber and
Blair sat down and Michael said to the
Prime Minister then former prime
minister said what should we have done
differently
and he said one thing we should have
been bolder and if I look back there are
things I should have been bolder about I
should have challenged the status quo
harder on I think there's a lot of work
that we need to do the good news is my
successor have plenty of opportunities
to find places to make changes I think
we need to professionalize teaching I
think we need to move much more
aggressively in this dynamic innovative
way I wish I started that sooner and
lastly and i've said this i really wish
i had figured out better ways to develop
more support we have plenty of support
but even more support because in the end
education is a political challenge and
building support making sure everybody
understands what you're doing and why
and getting them behind it it's a
critical piece of the puzzle excuse me
I'm from Roma and take a little bit
english i would like to ask you if you
think it's important to work on
preschool from three to six since we're
Roman we had a big number of school in
and we realized that it can be
successful for four months for the
future performances in the school system
to have this opportunity to the first
years of for the children to have this
kind of experience so if here in New
York City you think for a special
program in it and and also that I'm here
in the and i would like to cooperate
with the city of because we can offer
also
our experience in our school we have
also a special program for sports and
also damn elementary school or you know
UNESCO as as the problem the data
mediterranea is a special value and in
Rome we work a lot to to give them
supper in the school and in a in a in a
good way that can combat also yeah so so
also if you have program for this we
don't we have some programs i tell let
me say 17 first of all I only wish I
could speak Italian the way you speak
English so for your question grazie
Mille now I believe deeply were on the
preschool the early years we're making a
big mistake we're losing valuable
valuable time particularly in our most
challenged communities but it's got to
be good one of the questions people
always ask me well don't you want to
extend today extend a year yes but if we
don't get the quality piece right the
quantity piece will not get us there and
that's true on pre-k America had a huge
program when I walked that i watch
developed called head start and it got
very very iffy results because program
quality assurance wasn't there on
nutrition we actually do it at the
beginning of the day in terms of
breakfast we have some programs go later
in the evening important physical
education is critical we introduced
something called a fitness gram which is
our accountability measure in that
regard so those are all critical things
that you have talked about thank you all
very much
you